I actually gave a talk I need to I've
never had four screens or two
microphones so this is new for me I gave
a talk at PI data Carolina's two years
ago I think I can't remember the title
it's on YouTube but it's the the
substance of the talk was data
scientists and really aspiring data
scientists should be more proactive in
sharing things online I was very
inspired as I was getting in today to
science with 2010-2011 by seeing things
that people were sharing online at the
time who are in the early kind of data
science movement and I was like oh I'm
doing similarly interesting things in
grad school just nobody knows about it
and so I started to try to be more
proactive about sharing things online
and my my number one technique for doing
that is static websites that require no
maintenance so I do have a handful of
them Python plot comm these are all
linked from my website is a tool that
I've made to be useful to try to show
people how you can make just simple
exploratory plots in Python and should I
get a PhD com I did a number of years
ago now probably five years ago I did
interviews with six people in kind of
the tech data science type space some
with PhDs some without about the
questions I wish I had wrestled with
before dropping out of to PhD programs
prior to that so those are free you
could go and read those or you can buy
the the kindle or epub version and it's
the only thing I've ever successfully
monetized online and I've made like
probably fifty dollars yeah anyway I
I try to do things that are gonna be
that I know would be helpful to me and
try to make them available to be helpful
for others which actually
is a good intro to this talk so several
caveats one is I got moved into the
fairness and AI track because of
scheduling I need to leave this
afternoon uh supposed to be tomorrow so
if you're here hoping for a fairness and
I talk those are gonna start after me I
guess there's there's still time to
leave secondly I'm gonna deviate a
little bit from my proposal I think
there's another talk going on about air
flow right now if you want a talk more
about the nitty-gritty of air flow it
sounded like that was the place to be
and I'm gonna take this talk on a little
bit more of a meta level as as I try to
reflect on some things I've wrestled
with in my career in six years in data
science we're gonna see if I can make my
laptop more visible I'm taller than this
podium that's good and with that this is
a talk about I don't know if folks are
familiar with Robert Robert Chang I
think from Twitter wrote a blog post a
few years ago about type A and type B
data science where type a is more kind
of analysis type work and type B is more
like what now people are starting to
call machine learning engineering type
work so putting machine learning models
into production and I think the
profession of data science is and some
what some degrees diverging lease roles
are diverging although I think companies
are failing to recognize that so all
that to say this is a talk about my
experience on type B data science so
putting machine learning models into
products that are running into
production and the challenges that are
required to do that successfully and I
think a lot of companies in particular
non data scientists under estimate the
challenges of doing that effectively
which is really ultimately limiting them
so that's the the angle I'm going to
take on this and we'll discuss a little
bit of practical things as well so this
is my new favorite way to describe
myself as I used the handle TD hopper
online Twitter and my website and
various places so I searched TD hopper
on Google Image Search the other day
which I'd never done before and I think
actually the the recommended Google
Image Search recommends how you can make
your your topic more refined the first
recommendation is data science second is
dear Shelley processes which I have an
open-source package on nonparametric
dear Ashley processes for topic models
which you can find and hopefully not use
not because I don't want you to use it
because I I just don't think you should
use it it's not that good I'm an amateur
photographer I took several of these
pictures and in the thumbnails my
projects on github I have a blog post
about parallelizing Python for the
extremely lazy which is why that says
parallelizing and yeah anyway this is me
I I have a bunch of diverse interests
and things online and again I hopefully
those are helpful to you I work for a
company called silence we make antivirus
software we're one of several and
next-generation antivirus software
providers so we do model based detection
of malicious software which brings me
what to what I in the 2010-2011 thought
I might be doing as a data scientist
which was you know at the time reading
elements of statistical learning and
imagining you know the hard part of data
science was probably going to be
choosing what kernel went to my support
vector machines and turns out the six
years into my career I don't think I've
ever
should use the support vector machine
and my life is much less involved with
the nitty-gritty of linear algebra and
probability than I thought it would be
and it's much more in the nitty-gritty
of engineering challenges around data
science here's what my wife thinks I do
I work from home so she just sees me
sitting around various places in the
house with the laptop I showed her this
slide and she said I quote his hand
should be typing so that's early caveat
CEOs on the other hand CEOs of companies
that have machine learning products or
antivirus companies that are all about
using the term artificial intelligence
and their advertising just love to rave
about their data scientists and the
magic things that they do they they work
wonders and and turn a terrible data
into perfect predictions I imagine if
any of you are in similar companies
you've heard with horror the way
sometimes your data science team is
described by your CEO or your
salespeople and most of all you know I
never hear my CEO raving about how great
I am at you know fixing Pitts problems
and the things like that my boss you
know he knows more about the the day to
day the challenges that I face but then
we have these bigger scale visions of
what we want to do we want to be
shipping these machine learning models
into production and yet you know when he
comes to me for updates it so I spent
the whole last week and trying to figure
out how to get our dependencies aligned
in our versions of software things like
that he doesn't the moments where we
actually provide
are spending time refining our models
and getting our models out the door it's
such a small part of the the bigger
project that we're working on of course
I want people on Twitter and all of you
to think I spend all my time on the the
cutting edge of deep learning research
figuring out model architectures doing
the most amazing things with deep
learning I think there's a lot of
temptation for data scientists to feel
like that's where they need to be and
certainly there are lots of people doing
big things with deep learning but it's
definitely even if you're doing deep
learning it's maybe one of the easier
parts of of getting at the deep learning
is one of the easier parts of getting
the deep learning model into a
production system I was turned down from
a job a few years ago another one of the
things I've shared online actually is is
all the companies I've interviewed at
and gotten turned down for roles in the
last six years which I hope is helpful
to people sometimes I'm I'm known for
being a data science luminary on Twitter
and it's easy to see people online
especially if you're getting into the
industry it's easy to see people and
think they you know they have all this
great success and all these things and
I've been very fortunate my career in my
roles but I still get turned down by
jobs or for jobs so anyway all about to
say I got turned down from a job I had a
company that was a venture funded deep
learning company they had some well
known deep learning professors starting
this company they were hiring all these
former PhD students expertise and deep
learning and deep reinforcement learning
in particular and I gave the pitch
myself that you know I understand enough
of the deep learning but then I'm also
having this I think strong engine
airing skills and the ability to connect
those things together to help get your
products out the door
and I was turned down and given the
reason that I didn't know enough about
deep learning and the nuances of it for
the product which I think again to my
whole message of this talk is a very
short-sighted view if if you want to be
a company that has machine learning
models for deep lending models and
production and you are simply staffing
up with people whose expertise is deep
learning you're missing the whole rest
of the iceberg
I think icebergs are really cliche in in
business talks which I think this is a
little bit of a business talk but that's
that's the realities there's so much
that's so hard to do from an engineering
side that that can't be taken for
granted so what I actually do is you
know read github issues to trigger
figure out why I can't install certain
pip dependencies for all kinds of
projects I spend a huge amount of my
time working on problems like these
through using open source libraries
using libraries that we have internally
and you know obviously not just problems
but these types of challenges that I
think if you ask most practicing data
scientists unless they're in a company
that is very mature or has really
invested in these types of things a lot
of data scientists spend a huge amount
of their time solving what are
effectively pretty mundane technical
challenges so some examples of that how
do I install the Python dependencies for
my exploratory data analysis you know
simply making the decision in 2018 as to
what ways in which you want to manage
your Python dependencies is a challenge
there are now a number of different ways
you can do that you can use Kondo you
can use pip
you can use requirements not txt files
you can use setup tools you can use pip
em there are all these different options
out there and so even choosing is hard
and then once you've chosen getting
things to work the way you need is hard
filter and this says extra but should be
extract features from data snapshots on
s3 right many times where they decide to
serve higher into a company they say all
they have all this data and then it's
just some sort of disorganized chaos on
s3 and then it's up to you to figure out
how to get that data and maybe you're
gonna have to figure out how to spin up
an AWS spot instance with enough RAM to
load that data into pandas you maybe are
just left to that entirely on your own
how to get your instance how to make
sure it's secure how to get all your
dependencies installed so that you can
run Python maybe then you have to jump
through some hoops to get Python 3 on to
the AWS Linux AMI all these different
challenges then maybe you want to
configure ec2 instance and your VPN so
that you can access your Jupiter server
or your Drupal lab server from your
local computer right the jupiter runs in
the browser you're trying to run this
put your code on a on a remote machine
that doesn't have a GUI interface how do
you get that locally we've probably all
done some crazy port forwarding or SSH
tunneling at times to make something
like this work how do you translate your
site get results into a form that can be
re-implemented into production very
often and company's data scientists come
in they're using Python maybe they're
you know using other comparable things
like R or whatever your engineers who
are working on the product are using
some completely different stack they're
using maybe Java or scala JVM based
tools they're using go
and then you have this disconnect okay
I'm producing these models and
scikit-learn
how do I get these to run into my
production system so you do crazy things
to extract your results out of psych it
and then help your engineers we
implement those into the production
model how do I extract code and from
random scripts and notebooks and turn it
into a Python package again this is not
totally unique to Python but using
Python in a maintainable shareable clear
way where you don't this have folders
and folders full of scripts and
notebooks that only you know how to run
and understand where but instead have
tools that are generalized and able to
be run on multiple systems and using
Python in the way that has become
idiomatic in the sense of you hire
someone else you know something about
Python and they're going to be able to
come in and understand it and reuse it
it's a hard thing and it we take for
granted that that's an important skill
for a data scientist in 2018 maybe you
want to write shell scripts so that you
can bootstrap your ec2 machine to
reproduce your analysis so that every
time you need to do this analysis where
you have to spin up a machine that's big
enough to do it you don't have to go in
and remember some complex chain of you
know apt-get install commands to get all
these dependencies so you start to
recognize you need to standardize that
and you put that into a shell script
maybe after all this you decide to move
your Python environments inside docker
containers so that you don't have some
of the frustrations of getting your
dependencies installed on systems with
slightly different configurations or
missing different compiled libraries
maybe after you do that
want to figure out how to share your
docker images with the rest of the team
so that you're actually using docker in
a way that's valuable instead of just
rebuilding your images every time which
is sort of defeating the purpose I think
many of us have tried to build some kind
of dashboard to monitor the performance
of our model predictions in production
and we've jumped through various hoops
and and adapted tools to make them work
for our needs a challenge that many face
I think and and companies can easily
leave unsolved this how can you how do
data scientists schedule tasks to run on
a schedule repeatedly and in a way that
data scientists can deploy their own
tasks and have insight into them how
today the scientists do whatever people
do with kubernetes and worst of all last
but not least how do we configure AWS
permissions right it's security this is
not just because I work for a security
company but we security is one of the
most important aspects of computing
today as we just hear of company over
after a company that are having data
breaches and sometimes those data
breaches are their s3 buckets or public
that someone has you attackers
essentially right scrapers to just try
to to find s public s3 buckets and then
see if there's data in them that could
be valuable and many of us many
companies many data scientists are using
s3 or similar tools on the Google cloud
wherever to store their data and they're
trying to make this work in a
distributed fashion where they can
access it from different systems
different people in the company can
access it and the challenges around
configuring that correctly are really
hard they probably shouldn't fall on
data scientists but how often
do they do that so I'm trying to
understand this talk is really an
outworking and me trying to understand
why we have this lack of alignment
between talking about data scientists as
these researchers who understand machine
learning they understand math and
statistics and probability
they understand science the scientific
method all these different kinds of
things and yet in my experience talking
to data scientist day to day very few of
them actually spend all that much time
working on the problems around that
perceived not even perceived expertise
but this expertise they probably
actually have but they're their life day
to day is kind of these more mundane
engineering challenges does this
resonate
does anyone experience this in your in
your own work and I'll take those nods
as quiet amens I talk to a lot of people
who face this same thing and and I I'm
attempting to well I've spent time in my
own career trying to communicate this
reality internally in companies and try
to you know not not not in an attempt to
get out of work but an attempt to get
companies and get company leadership to
recognize the challenges of data science
and ultimately the challenges of running
machine learning models in production
are are much harder than they would
appear so the next few slides are
something I've wrestled over probably
more than any other talk and I'm still
not totally satisfied with it
so I would love to continue this
conversation with people if if you have
insight into this this is my attempt at
trying to understand why this is the
situation that we have and hopefully I
gave this talk to you to some of my
colleagues on Thursday and afterwards my
a very helpful colleague said so what
are you hoping people are going to take
away from this talk which really wasn't
clear and I've tried to clarify that but
might my takeaway for you assuming most
of you are our data scientists or
aspiring data scientists or something in
that realm and not vice-presidents or
the people that this talk is kind of
directed to my takeaway is twofold one
is I would like to continue to have this
discussion as this conversation as to
why we have these problems that we have
and secondly to try to give us all a
better framework for articulating the
challenges that we have and getting
companies to commit to solving these
challenges so that we can do effective
data science work so 0.1 I think is that
data scientists solve problems this is
for many of us this is one of our
greatest skills I think as I look back
on my own career I've been fortunate
with great education and great
opportunities but I think one of the the
main things I contribute to companies
that I'm just very tenacious and I just
will keep attacking a problem until I
can figure out how to solve it I think
for their many data scientists went to
grad school particularly those who are
in PhD programs this is one of the
things that helped them make it through
a ph.d program and they where they had
challenges and frustrations with poor
documentation detached advisors and
limited support for their work and they
were just forced to go out there figure
out how to solve the problems that
needed to be solved and power through
and get their research done
and many of us bring that kind of
mindset into our companies and I think
because data scientists as a role are
technical in that they are using
computers and programming to solve their
problems the and that they're because
they're problem solvers a temptation can
become and this maybe is true in smaller
companies rather than huge companies I
don't know but the temptation can become
for senior leadership to leave them to
solve all their technical problems
because they're capable of doing it so
therefore they should be doing it I
think the risk here is that sometimes we
or at least I can invent solutions that
are really Rube Goldberg machines and
they get the job done maybe they're even
cool to watch but they can be way overly
complicated and they can result in
having tons of components that need
constant maintenance that are things
that we shouldn't be spending our times
on and they can be opaque brittle
unmaintainable idiosyncratic solutions
to our problems if you don't resonate
with this I'm happy for you I think
there's a temptation for as I've already
saying the piece of engineering and you
know others who are in similar types of
leadership roles they leave their data
scientists to go solve their own
problems often and yet at the same time
they don't want their data scientists
being engineers and so as the data
scientists go out solving problems if
their solutions start to sound like
engineering solutions they might get the
breaks put on them that oh no you're not
engineers you shouldn't be building this
whole architecture you shouldn't be
building this engineering platform
all of your problem you're not we should
leave that to the engineers and yet they
don't my wife is going me and they don't
provide engineering resources needed to
solve the problems and so the result is
data scientists are left solving
problems in a kind of under the radar
way that ends up being a very
nearsighted solution from an engineering
perspective and they're building
technical debt they're building problems
that are only going to come down the
road because they're not allowed to and
maybe sometimes aren't even capable of
for no fault of their own building the
engineering solution that their data
science problem needs so we can end up
with these production models being
shipped and yet the they're not house
built on stain on sand where we have a
model and production that for all kinds
of reasons we are now unable to retrain
or maybe we're really unable to monitor
because we've built out the monitoring
tools we're unable to redeploy because
we had this manual massive deployment
process that was seen as our data
science work because we couldn't go and
build an engineering solution for this
problem that would make the deployments
work better and I think this is we can
be reflected in what I was already
describing about being turned down for
this job where data science teams or
groups are over represented in a way by
researchers and machine learning experts
and underrepresented in terms of the
needs by people who can solve these
engineering problems great data science
I believe needs great engineering
solutions it's it's tempting in
companies the same problem they can
think of
well machine learning models just need
some data so we just need to give our
machine learning experts our data
scientist access to the data and then
build something like a service that can
make predictions so it's this very
simple thing they get the data no
thought given to do they have labels on
their data that they can trade models
with and then they just need something
that can make predictions without
thinking about all kinds of engineering
challenges on both the micro and the
macro level so micro level we can think
about issues around can you install your
Python dependencies to do your analysis
and then macro level thinking more about
like architecture and larger scale
problems if you haven't read this
problem from Google or this paper from
Google I published a few years ago now a
paper called machine learning the high
interest credit card of technical debt
it's freely available from Google's
website and well the first two sentences
of the abstract really summarized in a
lot of ways the points I'm trying to
make machine learning offer offers a
fantastically powerful toolkit for
building complex systems quickly this
paper argues that it is dangerous to
think of these quick wins us coming for
free machine learning the paper argues
can introduce all kinds of technical
debt into your system that can in the
worst case make you have some kind of
production system that's making
predictions that you can't even touch or
improve over time they they enumerate a
number of examples from of hidden
feedback loops you can introduce and
systems to where you can't retrain your
model because you have feedback loops
from the effects of the previous model
you're unstable dependencies in your
data so you can't reliably get the data
that you need fix thresholds and dynamic
systems it's one of the sections where
you have you know these hard-coded
values that don't adapt as
the situation changes I think this is a
brief paper and it doesn't really
outline all the solutions but it raises
a lot of the concerns that can go on
here and I think the the the point I'm
trying to add to it is that often the
solution to these science type problems
are engineering solutions they're not
it's not that we need more math we just
need well better engineered solutions
and engineered solutions that understand
and can support the math and modeling
problems also in 2018 and this has been
true for a long time but is really
becoming acknowledged over the last ten
years particularly as we've moved to
cloud-based architectures that great
engineering needs infrastructure and
operations and and that becomes a huge
part of the engineering challenges today
you think about how much time you might
spend writing code versus how much time
you spend configuring AWS and and the
like this whole movement you've probably
heard the term DevOps this has been a
movement over the last ten years and you
may not understand
I think there's often misunderstandings
of what that term means and it doesn't
have a single definition which is a
challenge it doesn't really necessarily
even have a single history but generally
it's regarded and this is a quote from
Atlassian's website I think it's as good
as any DevOps is a set of practices that
automates the processes between software
development and IT teams in order that
they can build test and release software
faster and more reliably the concept of
DevOps is focused on building a culture
of collaboration between teams that
historically function in relative silos
and the promised benefits include
increased trust faster software releases
ability to solve critical
issues quickly and better manage
unplanned work as a as a theory the idea
of DevOps was for developers and
operations to come together and work
together in a way that allows software
to be released more quickly more things
to be automated things to be captured in
code versus just in people's heads or in
documentation ability for engineers to
make a faster and more frequent small
more frequent updates automating deploys
so that you don't have people knowing
some sort of complex manual way to
deploy something and also a security
focus on your infrastructure and
operations and when that works well from
a software perspective you move the
things into automation that can be
automated as much as possible and those
things can you know be built quickly and
then you can focus on the product the
problem that you're trying to solve and
not just spinning your wheels all the
time with these operational challenges
yet the reality is if you have a DevOps
team many times DevOps teams can hinder
DevOps
practice so companies are renaming or
naming their operations type team DevOps
but they're not actually doing them up
so you still have these silos you don't
have this company you don't have these
teams working together and so your
DevOps can become a blocker to moving
quickly where you maybe make requests
and they never get fulfilled or they
just enter a queue and they take weeks
before the thing happens that you need
so then you have this situation we're on
the road to success there are no
shortcuts
and yet you try to take a shortcut and
you don't get success
and as so DevOps is this idea of
developers and operations coming
together I think this is a mindset and a
principle philosophy that we need in
data science and yet
adding machine learning systems into
this whole picture simply makes this
whole thing more complicated it becomes
an even harder problem to solve and just
allowing all of the responsibilities to
fall on data scientists I think as
companies often shooting themselves in
the foot and and being successful with
data science this is a tweet from a
couple months ago Pete Hummer was
LinkedIn and kind of the heyday of
LinkedIn data science and this has been
a leader in the data science community
over the last ten years and he tweeted a
couple months ago as a rule of thumb you
can expect the transition of your
enterprise company to machine learning
will it be a beat about a hundred times
harder than your transmission transition
to mobile and he didn't really go into
great depth explaining this I think he
was thinking through this and planning a
talk of his own but I think companies
really fail to miss this point and I've
tried to outline some ways in which
that's happened so maybe what we need is
they decide DevOps where we both have
data signs and developers working
together and developers and operations
working together and operations and data
science working together we instead of
you know just two aspects of the
developers and operations working
together we need this integration across
all these teams which is a hard and
expensive prospect for companies and and
maybe you know people have already
realized this in we see an emerging role
of machine learning engineer who are
more focused on these types of problems
and who are supported by their companies
in solving these problems
I think I suspect many data scientists
who are in roles like mine are
fulfilling a role that would be more
better called machine learning engineer
and yet my perception is companies are
have been you know think all these
things are changing so fast in data
science just appeared and but maybe it
needs to already be divided in a way
that makes more sense for the success of
the company but at the end of the day
what we need is leadership of companies
to stop thinking that there's you know
this magic unicorn roll of data
scientists who can fulfill all these
tasks and execute them in an effective
way
again great machine learning is in
products is gonna require great
engineering and great operations and
without that foundation built and that
working together through the lifecycle
of a product I think companies are going
to fail to successfully put machine
learning models into production I will
break it I think the session ends in
four minutes is that right all right so
if there any quick questions
you take that but I don't want to hold
you up from getting to later talks
all right thank you all very much
[Applause]